do you realize that when you are an
entrepreneur you sometimes have to go to
court yes what's up my name's samuel
leeds my net worth is 20 million pounds
i started with nothing and in this video
i'm going to be giving you some
informative news in how you can get
started in property let me tell you
something martin lewis martin lewis the
guy who's money expert money super
saving expert whatever he is recently
came out and said as the money saving
expert who's been known for this
i am virtually out of tools to help
people now it's not something money
management can fix it's not something
for those on the lowest incomes telling
them to cut their belts will work energy
prices are almost doubling at the moment
this year everything's going up the only
thing that's not going up is wages so
you need to become an entrepreneur
that's what i did when i was 17 years
old became an entrepreneur became a
millionaire by 25.
now
i'm um i'm very successful but i tell
you something i always vowed never to
hide away when i become successful i'm
not going to hide away i'm going to pull
other people up with me so yeah i'm
going to get away
in a couple of days i'm going to the
bahamas
cayman islands
mexico miami but i'm still going to be
doing youtube videos sharing i'm
investing all across the world right now
i've got some exciting projects
potentially lined up overseas but anyway
this is the most four common questions
that i've been asked this week around my
live property i'm gonna be talking some
very controversial topics right now on
this update i'm gonna be talking about
some court cases going on do you realize
that when you are an entrepreneur you
sometimes have to go to court i'm going
to be showing some controversy in this
video i'm also going to be talking about
what property prices are going to do
this year 2022 here in the uk and
potentially across the world as well i'm
gonna be talking about how to buy
properties in 2022 using non of your own
money how to buy houses effectively free
houses
do you know that they're printing
hundreds of billions of pounds just in
the uk there's so much money being
printed when you know how to get a hold
of some of that money
and invest it in real estate you can
create so much wealth when you know what
you're doing and i'm also going to be
sharing a huge challenge literally you
know what i was doing a few days ago i
was dry not driving i was flying around
the country in a helicopter trying to
find big juicy development projects i'm
gonna be sharing with you on this video
what i found so let's get started first
if you enjoy my channel do me a favor
hit the like button if you're not
subscribed already subscribe so number
one
i'm gonna get to the court case towards
the end of the video super controversial
um number one what a property price
you're gonna do property prices have
been going up the last couple of years
by 10 every year it's been absolutely
booming so my prediction of 2022 i think
that house prices are going to continue
to go up but i don't think they're going
to be as
crazy booming as they were last year
last year we had things like the stamp
duty holidays we had um
the the mortgage relief there was just a
lot of incentives
and i think people were just trying to
jump on that bandwagon so it was
everyone was jumping into property now
it's still popping so my prediction is
this year i think house prices will rise
by around about six percent let's watch
the video back in a year's time
and we'll see how right i was every time
i do a prediction video i'm always
pretty much bang on how do you buy a
house if using none of your own money
four ways write these down you won't get
this content elsewhere on youtube just
from the samuel lee's channel write this
down number one way is you can control
properties instead of owning properties
this is called rent to rent which is
where and people think oh that's like
subletting oh that's just for losers
that that basically end up with another
job no it's not this is what premiere in
do premiere in rent buildings from big
land owners
okay they rent the building and then
they turn it into a premier inn and make
a bucket load of cash every month that's
called rent to rent you can do this with
just a little simple studio apartment
man you can rent a studio apartment for
500 pounds a month in somewhere like
birmingham and then you can with the
right permissions and contracts
put that studio apartment on airbnb and
rent it out for a hundred pounds a day
you don't need a lot of money to get
started in this you can get no you can
pay no deposit you can get rent free
periods from the landlord the landlord
wants to do it because he's got a long
lease the landlord wants to do it
because he's got no management company
to have to pay he's got no tenants to
deal with because if you're if you're
renting off him you're not a tenant
because it's not your home so you don't
have any tenants rights neither do your
guests from airbnb because it's not
their home they're not tenants they're
guests so you get around the whole
eviction issues
great service great way to get started
in property second way
is
by buying a house on a lease option
agreement this is when you buy now pay
later so you buy a house agree to pay
for it in seven years time who would do
this people that don't need or can't get
the money now third way is joint venture
put get angel investors to put the money
in you find the deal you do all the work
you take a percentage of the profit and
the fourth way is to package and sell
deals find investments pass them to
invest stores and charge a fee in the
middle anyway bang like the video if you
enjoyed it next up court case
emotional week this week um
yeah so this you know what um in 2019
some of you will remember if you've been
watching me for for a few years
there was a hate campaign against me
there was a bunch of internet trolls
that were commenting on all my videos
all my social media stuff some of them
were really bad some of them were
sending stuff personal messages to me
writing to my wife and anyway we pressed
charges against one of the key
corporates and this week
this week last week a few days ago he
was found guilty in the courtroom and
they literally the judge was really
harsh on him he got like 180 hours over
a 12-month period of community service a
criminal record court fines five-year
restraining order
bang it was a victory justice was served
so if you want more about that i'm going
to leave it in the description and you
can hear me talking about what happened
in court but really really really
important lesson for people that are
number one trolls you know it's illegal
what you do and stop it but also i
didn't just do this for me but also
anyone that's in business and you're
doing videos or if you're putting
yourself out there and you're getting
attacked you don't have to just ignore
it you know you can sue these people you
can press charges against these people
so that was great um so yeah check check
the link in the description you'll find
out more about that but on a more
positive note
this is going to blow you away the
helicopter house hunts i hired a
helicopter spent the day with a
celebrity jordan haynes namely and we
literally went out for the down
helicopter he wanted to find a deal that
would make him quarter of a million
pounds profit in a day and it was just
the most amazing thing ever so i'm going
to play you right now a sneak peek of
the helicopter house hunt and then on
the end screen you can click through and
watch the full video on my other channel
undercover millionaire so stay tuned
watch this 30 second clip and click
through and watch the full thing enjoy
what's up my name is samuel leeds and
today i'm on a mission to try and find a
really juicy property investment deal
i'm going to be looking at houses all
across the country trying to source
something for a celebrity guest this is
the helicopter house hunt let's go
[Music]
four eight times